[Musique]
oui mais qu absolument nous sommes ici
pour ce troisième rendez vous françois
centre val de loire et le 500e
anniversaire de la naissance et de la
mort dans l'âme arts de nancy
nous sommes au château de gien château
qui comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure et bien un château qui est prêt
renaissance pour on en parlera tout à
l'heure c'est aussi le musée de la
chasse et comme on l'est à gien on va
parler bien entendu de faïence mais
avant toute chose petite leçon
d'histoire avec le petit rat cher
illustré regarder un château quasi
royales remaniée par anne de beaujeu en
1481 elle reçoit le comté de gien en
apanage de son père louis 11 une sorte
de compensation car étant une femme hèle
n'accéderaient pas au trône femme de
tête elle pratiquait aussi la
fauconnerie
alors il ya une dame qui a fait
construire le château qui s'appelle anne
de beaujeu et qui chassait haut vol
c'était une chasse facile à réaliser
pour les femmes et c'est pour ça qu'elle
était très apprécié
raison du trône de france anne de
beaujeu jouera un rôle majeur c'est dans
ce château qu'elle protégera son petit
frère alors âgée de 13 ans le futur cher
le 8 le nouveau château est alors
pourvue des commodités kelly a fait
installer
on va aussi retrouver des traces de
confort j'irai en termes de vie
quotidienne et notamment avec la
présence des tubes de salle des bains de
latrines donc voila tu vraiment des
choses pour la vie quotidienne et qui
rendent la vie quotidienne beaucoup plus
confortable j'ai ainsi particulier avec
ses briques polychrome et ses motifs
dont la symbolique reste encore obscur
aujourd'hui j1 est un château avec une
architecture sans prétention ça peut
s'apparenter à une sirène prime abord on
peut aussi dire que c'est une mélusine
c'est pas vraiment en fait
on est sur la décoration purement et
simplement ce ne sont pas des
gargouilles pour terroriser les pigeons
comme on peut trouver sur les
cathédrales et les autres monuments
l'oriel c'est un balcon un petit balcon
de sur deux étages où en fait on peut se
tenir à une ou deux personnes
donc c'est vraiment juste pour
contempler
autour les environs c'est purement
décoratif pour à la mort d'anne de
beaujeu le chat tout reviendrait à la
couronne et juste avant de partir pour
les guerres d'italie françois 1er
viendra à gien pour confier la régence à
sa mère louise de savoie
un sujet signé mélanie trèche l'heure et
nous allons tenter de retourner à gien
au château de juin où nous attend denis
egan est meilleur en direct pour nous
faire vivre ces festivités des 500 ans
de la renaissance
on me fait signe en régie que la liaison
est coupée eh bien en attendant on va
voir tenter de voir ce reportage sur la
récolte des asperges dans le berry un
reportage de catherine lacroix
qu'il pleuve qu'il vente ou qu'il fasse
soleil la récolte des asperges commence
à 6 heures du matin c'est aspergeraie
berrichonne a été planté en 2005
sa particularité produire des asperges
vertes
cette année sera sa deuxième année de
pleine production
le travail ne manque pas pour les cinq
meilleurs éleveurs
c'est une activité qui n'est pas
mécanisée voir pas mécanisables on a
quelques chariots qui nous permettent
d'attirer la récolte pour porter les f
les spurs ont ramassé une par une chaque
jour la culture des asperges vertes est
très différente à l'oeil de celle des
asperges blanches
ici le couvert est très fourni une
volonté du producteur on va avoir fait
la conversion en bio en 2009 mais on a
fait le pari avec avec mon frère de
travailler sans aucun pesticide
uniquement avec des solutions naturelles
après plus de cinq heures passées dans
les champs sous une pluie battante le
groupe rejoint l'atelier où le travail
va continuer
il faut maintenant trier et préparer la
récolte du jour donc ici on conditionne
les asperges donc le produit brut arrive
on le pose sur les tapis roulants et
ensuite on alimente la machine ici avec
les asperges elles sont coupées par la
cie ensuite à sont lavés elles sont
triées en fonction de trois calibres
donc les asperges pin les acteurs de
taille moyenne
c'est une culture qui est très
dépendante du temps donc comme
aujourd'hui on a un temps pluvieux magne
récolte a fait moyenne donc là ça
représente lui de bonne heure de conte
canaux après cela il reste à mettre en
bottes les asperges pour la quasi
totalité de la récolte à l'aide là aussi
d'une machine
un travail long et coûteux en main
d'oeuvre qui explique le prix mais pour
le producteur
le produit le mérite principal avantage
c'est vraiment qu'on ne juge pas ou très
peu qu'elle est beaucoup plus tendre et
on a la possibilité de faire une
multitude de recettes avec une multitude
de cuisson on travaille avec quelques
grossistes quelques drones furtifs
également mais on privilégie surtout la
vente directe puisque les deux tiers de
nos ventes se font en vente directe
18h30 la vente directe à la ferme
commence deux points de vente sont
ouverts auxquels s'ajoutent plusieurs
marchés ce département dont chapeau coup
petit à petit le nombre d amateurs de ce
légume très différent de sa cousine la
blanche grossit en berry et nous avons
rétabli la liaison avec le château
devient on nous attend denis gagné pour
nous faire vivre les 500 ans de la
renaissance de nyon vous avez perdu
où êtes-vous oui tout à fait je suis
toujours au château de girard je ne sais
pas ainsi les asperges et et ont mangé
des asperges à leur renaissance
bonjour dans les pierres je voudrais
qu'on parle tout de suite de cette
tapisserie qui elle alors si le château
et je lui ai dit tout à l'heure près
renaissance et renaissance
cette tapisserie totalement renaissance
oui en effet c'est une tapisserie qui
date du 16e siècle qui a été tissée dans
les flandres et qu'ils aient vent que
une chasse aujourd'hui disparue où
pratiquement disparu c'est la chasse à
les pieux qui est un manque est une arme
de j'ai un petit peu lancé comme un
comme un javelot et la sueur à nos rock
qui lui est un de taureaux sauvages au
taureau sauvage
oui c'est tout ça peut être assez
rustique quand même je pense cette
chasse alors bien entendu ce château de
girard est aussi un musée je disais le
musée de la chasse on va on va circuler
un petit peu dans ce musée c'est
principalement on y voit pas trop la
chasse à courre
on y voit principalement quand même la
chasse à tir alors on y voit également
la chasse à courre
je me fais combat oui attention oui
toutes les chatteries sont évoqués dans
ce dans ce musée
la chasse au vol la chasse à courre la
vénerie et bien entendu la chasse à
tient dans laquelle nous nous trouvons
actuellement absolument avec une très
belle collection de deux toutous qui
sont derrière moi serais tu vois là et
le rebond avec des illustrations et ça
je voudrais qu'on y revienne parce que
ce sont de très très très belles pièces
dont celle là qui est là qui est une
illustration donc de la chasse à cette
époque là elle est superbe
oui c'est un portrait de chasseurs qui
date du xviiie siècle qui a un
raffinement temps dans le paysage que
dans le costume la posture du chien les
détails des guêtres du personnage son
attitude en font effectivement une
oeuvre remarquable et on a déjà cette
notion de perspective
1 oui c'est là qu'elle est arrivée merci
en tout cas nous avons reçu toute cette
journée
vous savez qu'on est curieux et on a
réussi on a réussi à aller dans un
endroit où finalement on ne devait pas
aller
je ne dis rien je remercie m reregarder
s'étaient tournés cet après midi alors
là vous l'avez compris nous sommes dans
les combles du château déjà commandé
très très curieux et qu'on a rencontré
une médiatrice culturelle et bien on a
négocié avec l on soit leur âme ça va
leur âne
on est en effet dans cet endroit qui est
absolument magnifique qu'est ce que l'on
pourrait appeler la forêt mais ce ne
serait pas de bon ton en ce moment
d'appeler comme ça c'est donc cette
cette charpente du château sur les
combles tout simplement oui les derniers
niveaux
la charpente ça se visite pas du tout
non ça c'est secret c'est de privilégier
des privilégiés c'est bien merci pour
les téléspectateurs de france 3 5 2
alors ce qu'on va voir ici finalement
elle n'est pas très ancienne parce que
malheureusement en 1940 le feu a pris
dans cette partie justement
oui la ville de gien a été ravagé par
les bombardements en juin 1940
la ville a été détruite incendiés et ces
incendies se sont propagés jusqu'au
château jusqu'à cette charpente et
beaucoup penser à l'époque que le
château était perdu et finalement c'est
une pluie d'orage providentiel qui a
permis d'arrêter les flammes
1 c'est génial ça orages providentiel
comme quoi la pluie du foie un faux
passeport et c'est resté très longtemps
à ciel ouvert avant oui oui mais pour la
ville plus de 1300 bâtiment a été
partiellement complètement détruit
rapidement ils ont voulu reconstruire la
ville et restaurer le château et
reconstruire l'église mais il a fallu
attendre la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale pour que ces grands projets de
reconstruction soient lancées alors on
pourrait se dire que éventuellement si
ces endroits étaient habités apparemment
il était habité peut-être par le
personnel et je sais que vous tenez à
m'emmener dans un endroit bien précis
c'est ça un peu peur moi un endroit très
intimement ni la droite réseau team
bombe alors il un endroit très sensible
je vous suis les yeux fermés attention
voilà ça passe grille au moins ça a
l'air c'est un peu noir non il ya de la
lumière mais là il y en a plus up
ah ben ouais ce que j'en ai alors on a
toujours on a toujours cette magnifique
charpente
on voit que ça a été refait pratiquement
comme à l'époque je veux dire c'est pas
une construction c'était reconstruit
mais pas de façon moderne
donc c'est bien et qu'est ce qu'il ya de
particulier
olala des latrines c'est quoi ça c'est
ça mais latrines
ils se sont dits d'attribuer vous voulez
m'emmener donc exactement exacte des
latrines c'est aux toilettes
alors c'est assez étonnant quand même ça
de trouver ça dans les comptes c'était
donc bien habiter alors oui il ya dans
ce logis à des latrines comme celle ci
il y avait dans tous les niveaux
tous les niveaux tout raccrocher à un
conduit tant dans une fois ce don alors
au niveau de l'intimité c'est pas c'est
parce qu'on prenne au niveau du confort
pas terrible non plus non scellées et il
fallait pas être gêné par quelqu'un skis
parce qu il me semble pas qu'il y ait eu
de choses entre les deux qua non bon
voilà des latrines
alors donc quand on était en bas on
avait quand même la possibilité d'aller
aux héroïnes dans tous les niveaux il y
avait des latrines tous les niveaux
voilà c'est la première fois que j'en
vois comme ça
merci pour ce pour cette visite assez
extraordinaire quand même parce que
c'est rare de voir ce genre de choses et
dire qu'il ya des gens qui ont passé des
heures la ba ba oui des oeuvres alors
est-ce que question est-ce que léonard
de vinci avait pensé à des petites
toilettes modernes à des latrines
moderne alors j'ai regardé dans les
codex bien entendu sur les documents
qu'a laissé l'honneur demain si je n'ai
pas trouvé mais en revanche ici à gien
il a inspiré les créateurs de la
faïencerie de gien car ils ont fait une
collection de faïences d'un dédié
justement à l'erreur de l'acier alors on
regarde ensemble le reportage de corinne
bien rosa et de pierres de munich
ep boire son café en compagnie des
machines de léonard de vinci ou déguster
un gâteau en contemplant les esquisses
du maître les petites mains de la
faïencerie de gien décline la
renaissance sur décalcomanie
[Musique]
pour moi le plus délicat et je pense que
mes collègues diront la même chose je
pense que c'est ce porte cartes dès
l'instant qu'il ya des angles a à faire
il faut absolument éviter toutes les
bulles qui peut y avoir à l'intérieur
puisque ça posera un problème après donc
ça ira au second choix
donc est ce qu'il faut éviter un maximum
gien et la renaissance une petite
histoire dans la grande histoire qui a
commencé avec le travail des faïenciers
itinérant ces artisans qui vendaient au
19e siècle leur décor inspiré de cette
époque sans en renaissance italienne
renaissance italienne
c'est un thème qui est très fortement
aux associés lien et puis léonard de
vinci s'est entamé un thème universel et
sans thème nouveau que nous avions envie
de l'explorer
à l'époque la belle vaisselle était un
signe de richesse pour restituer
l'univers de léonard de vinci
les créateurs maisons ont travaillé à
partir de reproduction des codex les
carnets de notes de l'italien
nous sommes partis de planches
d'archivés comme celle ci donc qui
ensuite après sont donc scanner et notre
travail de recomposer piocher certains
éléments pour après les recomposer selon
les gabarits soit d'une assiette comme
moyenne 6 soit un pic poche selon les
pièces d'un et casse du service
les 500 ans de la renaissance une
aubaine pour la faïencerie mille pièces
sortiront des fours de juin pour être
vendus dans les châteaux de la loire
cet été voilà cette magnifique
collection regarder cette belle image
c'est une faïence de deuxième je suis
avec l'amiens ou merzouk fois la gelée
bien prononcé qui est là dit la
directrice de la responsable de ce musée
de wii 2 devient alors
on a vu qu est ce que la renaissance
parce qu'on voit là léonarde ainsi les
designers bien entendu haut
d'aujourd'hui
regarde tout ce qui suit quelles sont
les tendances mais à partir de la
renaissance à une présence réelle dans
la faïencerie de gien présence à la fois
réel et très forte et ce depuis 1865
dès les années 1860 5 la faïencerie
devient s'est nourri de modèles dire aux
italiens
voilà des choses absolument magnifique
qui sont là et regardez là on a même
donc vous voyez c'est guillaume qui vous
le monde c'est françois 1er absolument
autour c'est un peu en retrait de
françois 1er qui apparaît sur ce plateau
des guerres françois 1er qui est une
figure très très récurrente dans nos
dans nos produits sont d'accord alors
j'imagine que on dit 500 ans de
renaissance mais justement à la
faïencerie aussi on va parler de
vaisselle on va parler on rentre à
partir du moment où la décence démarre
on catherine de médicis amène la
fourchette je dire on commence à avoir
un confort de table qui est loin de
l'époque médiévale on pense vraiment à
être plutôt raffinée on est
effectivement plutôt racines et on aime
la très belle vaisselle on aime les
belles décorations et pour ce qui nous
concerne à la fois entreprises d'arts de
la table est aussi créateur de pièces
décoratives d'accord aujourd'hui est-ce
que l'on va est ce que l'on va encore
chercher des choses est ce que les gens
sont intéressés pour retrouver de ces
périodes différentes de la renaissance
ou pas ah oui bien sûr oui on a la foi
des collectionneurs et des amateurs qui
sont à la recherche de modèles anciens
parmi lesquels la renaissance italienne
merci là bien d'avoir été notre invité
juste vous parler d'un événement qui
aura lieu le 29 et 30 juin
ça sera superbe ces 500 cavaliers
pour les 500 ans de chambord et on va
écouter pascal debout qui est le co
président du comité régional
d'équitation qui nous parle de cet
événement a ses exceptions on écoute on
aura mis en place des kilomètres et des
kilomètres de chemins en région qui sont
des chemins qui on a travaillé comme une
autre avec la région avec les
départements pour obtenir que ces
chemins se resteront des chemins qui
seront destinés à la à l'itinérance à la
circulation douce et particulièrement la
circulation équestre est sèchement là
seront balisés donc facile aujourd'hui
on a ainsi que s'appelle jeanne cherhal
point com où on peut découvrir
l'ensemble des itinéraires équestres en
france est particulièrement réjouissant
de la loi voilà c'est ainsi que l'on va
se quitter
je vais regarder dehors ce magnifique
château regardez à on se retouve voilà
rebecca c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
était donc troisième rendez vous ici au
château de gien la semaine prochaine on
est enchanté ça sera l'uci qui vous
accompagnera je souhaite une excellente
soirée
à bientôt